let's talk about 2020 polling okay it's
been weeks since I talked about the
Democratic primary polling partially
it's because I was gone all of last week
but partially it's because we've not
been following it super closely at this
point but we're now getting close to the
start of the Democratic primary debates
those start next month and at this point
there are some really clear and defined
trends in 2020 Democratic primary
polling and the trends are for better or
worse Joe Biden is leading but not by as
much as he was at the beginning of May
Bernie and Elizabeth Warren have
solidified their second and third place
positions Kamala Harris and Peter Budaj
are kind of trading back and forth for
the fourth place position and then
they're just like are a whole bunch of
candidates who can't even break one or
one percent or two percent who are
effectively done and have no chance so I
want to go through this in order and
let's see kind of what we're left with
at the end first of all the Green Line
if you are watching along with me here
is Joe Biden's polling and I'll describe
it in case you're listening and not
watching Joe Biden's polling hit a high
average of more than 40% early in May
and it's now sort of cooled off to just
under 35 percent so Biden has lost
somewhere around six or seven points
depending on the poll you look at over
the last three to four weeks the
question is is Biden going to keep
trailing off or will he stick around 35%
the progressive wing of the left is
saying the more people know about Joe
the more his support is going to erode
because people aren't going to like what
Joe Biden is about that's a possibility
it also could be that there was some
initial enthusiasm behind Joe that is
just kind of falling off now okay so
that's number one number two you look at
the light blue and the brown lines on
this image that's on screen
those are Bernie and Warren and I'll
describe to you what's going on there
Bernie was immediately hurt when Joe
Biden entered the race and you see that
when Biden hit his high of around 40
plus percent
Burnie hit his low but he's since
recovered and Bernie's now pretty
solidly in second place pulling an
average of just over 16 percent now
elizabeth warren on the other hand as i
told you a couple of weeks ago has been
slowly and steadily growing her support
and it's now at a campaign high she's
moved from being kind of in the 5% area
to 7 to 8 percent in most polls she's
now averaging right about 10 percent
behind Bernie Sanders but not
drastically so so let's now look now
that we've seen who the three
frontrunners are let's look at who's
done and has no chance the frontrunners
clearly Joe Biden Bernie Sanders
Elizabeth Warren behind them and then
there's the second sort of mini tier of
candidates which is Kamala Harris and
Pete Budaj edge Harris averaging about
7% Budaj edge averaging about 6% now the
people who have no chance and are
getting no traction and will likely
start dropping out soon after the
debates start are the folks who are
under 1% for sure and a lot of the
people under 2% as well okay so under 1%
and have no chance whatsoever
tulsi gabbard Bennet Bullock whom you
may not even have heard of Hickenlooper
Seth Moulton Bill DeBlasio john delaney
kirsten gillibrand marianne williamson
tim ryan they're all under 1% they just
have no chance ok I'm not telling them
to drop out I don't really care one way
or the other they're just non factors
they're done and I don't even know that
there's that much attention to be paid
to their prospects then you have the 1
to 2 percent range
oK you've got Andrew yang there you have
who Leon Castro you have Amy Klobuchar
who are between one and two percent
they're all so realistically done but if
you're at 2% you can sort of justify
staying in a little bit longer I know
that early I said I liked Andrew yang
and I still like Andrew yang I know that
three months ago he had like a
hypothetical path to the nomination if
he continued building support I'm not
calling him done now
I mean he's over 1% but if he doesn't
get to like 3 or 4% after the first
I don't know how he justifies staying in
and then caught in this kind of no-man's
land at more than 2% but less than
anything significant our cory booker at
2.2 and Beto or work at 3.8 I think
they're also both done but that's enough
support to keep raising money keep
raising your public profile by staying
in so that's my assessment right now if
you disagree with me on any of this let
me know politely ideally if there's
someone in the under 1% area that you
think has a shot tell me who and tell me
why if there's someone who's polling
more than 3% and you do think they
should get out right now tell me who and
tell me why and if you think that
there's someone who isn't doing well but
as soon as they get on the debate stage
they are going to be so impressive to
the voting public that they will rock it
up into at least the seven eight or nine
percent range
tell me who and tell me why people will
be so impressed with their debate skills
we'll follow up we'll do a poll on the
YouTube community tab about this and see
where our audience is on a lot of these
candidates and issues